rebound back the other way and here's
barov just looks off Reinhard on the
far side challenges the glove hand why did
you think like hey you know what we got a
good shot at this it was interesting I
thought he'd say game five or game six
here's a chance in front and they score barov
sets up Reinhardt backand and Marion tips it
over Saka to poock to [Applause] a back foot
snapshot a generous bounce PA [Applause]
zaka now fetch nikov trying to make a stick
handling play in the for you get it in the
slot send it cross with the score oh what a pass
from Fetch COV ten the heart no stick is so he
hasn't been able to get back and get it let's
see if the fers can get get it deep so that he
can retrieve it yeah there he goes he get it deep
and there's tippet he scores now he's got the puck
big Nick who set ice on the right side loton
back to delore delore tried to Center second
try to have the way he's down Co kenami was fetch
nikoff n and a crosso score Bunning Carolina wins
it clean and Michael Bunning low Drive side
to the net his heart Teri it in the SL store
Tav terrain his eighth of the season now they do
it's Riley Smith for Eric Carlson Malin takes the
pass chips it to Carlson drives it scores to the
middle of the ice across for silverberg silverberg
wanted to find henrique in front it bounc right
to Jones who hacked it on net and then kick down
by silverberg who stick handles it into the net
put enough on it then it's spotted right back
out so the Ducks tag up and now McTavish little
stop and go drops it off fower walks down the
slot hands it off patlo scores Carlson takes it
Marin one timer [Applause] scor G Mao backand
feet up the wall knocked down by Eller zahor to
the goal in front o Conor with a drive a save
made go stall rebound [Applause] zahor 125 of
the third and the penguins have the lead back
mnov steps up stro in front Mavish scores what a
big time play by Mason Mavish here's malan again
first penalty over out of the box Mavis tipped
to him short-handed score Bon Mavis up top dlan
is shot body down by Johansson Schwarz reset
Schultz shot kicked out they score it's Brian
Duman three to the wall yamamoto's on it to the
slot wide open G he scores the pepper pot right
on his spot Celli puts it back to Line This is
radish radish works it across to flurry flurry
in front trying to find a tip scores tapped into
the side of the net out in front maybe Johansson
got a piece of it done one timer to it and denied
by Johansson they score on the rebound it's Tyler
Yamamoto one minute remaining in this lightning
power play second unit on there Sur with shot lose
there for R dear Alex bar ble up ahead to Bar
ble Cuts back hangard puts it into the corner
for sell pass got through him but it's picked up
now by Hegel back in front danar Brandon Hao res
situate with borran dun McAn scores hey hey what
do you say now to Brink it carries in wrestled
away from him by cus Corvette hustling cikas has
a step he's in and a score it's in bounce to the
net and that one to lud whoo but was well wide
and Raymond behind gave it away to angal angal
looking at doson Dobson one timer score in the
third have been the two goals in this game and
whoo's been great too Red Wings coming in for
sprung scores back to the point and a shot by
Walman hit a body Rass houon and wman insisting
on the strle they score CP carries it back down
low they score coer from cider what a beautiful
pass as Horvat scks it around towards Nelson now
doson marzelle horback [Applause] [Music] SC
here's Raymond again across back scar R it
for CER and that video and all that is going to
come keep been chances like that in will trupal
with room that's a pass to flick it in he grabs
the hold of that pu brings it into the Rangers
zone for Fetti pass over a shot and a ball for
guson and now a potential two onone yes Here
Comes Peretti with elers a pass in front to
Peretti couldn't put it home eer still has a
r r he [Music] scored now Mo for CER tro panan
outside Fox quick shot it's SC Keandre Miller
does he have another gamewinner in that stick
P saan he scores they punch it to the corner
check throwing there as the Stars bring it to
neutral a Robertson he's got help of cutting
Harley Robertson Harley he scores and now he
can settle down after that big save walking
out of the corner backhanded There by Kent Johnson
little Tic Tac to scores his first National Hockey
League goal jacket's control as a result of the
offensive zone here Wiki to get that shot through
Ricochet now fantell comes off the wall nice pass
there scores theyve had multiple scoring chances
some tired jackets as the Stars Top Line controls
off the face off lanquist up high Robertson shot
score left side sudor with a blast save rebound
scored Matt Duan checks the mirror sees he's
got time lifts it out to the Columbus Blue
Line juggling Johnston right side shot score
to [Music] donov Ben and it's handed off to
donov he's got Johnston in all alone for the
empty net but since that third goal and really
was a better period in the third off the back
wall and there car overtime against Vegas on
Friday to start this road trip Kevin kinsky
now pass across Bard [Applause] scores play out
of his own and steter paired tonight right or
paired right now as Sha dersy steter will go to
the bench has a chance in front carcone scores
ja MC smartly sends one deep Kuro is there so
is Seth Jones Liam O'Brien comes in Coyote's
free it shot on rebound they score huge St and now
Krauss across carcone and he scores carcone tries
to drop a [__] in front looking for a rebound
and it's underneath and Carone just missed it it
comes in and they score 41 they've been in this
position before they were in this position last
game and now curut to McBain he scores oh he go
to the bench and the coyotes kill it off Michael
Carone after it Travis Boyd has it back to the
front Jersy Stars you love the fact that a guy
like Le m brown they all continue to same play
the same way McBain with a shot rebound oh it's
put home no goal McBain right down the middle
tried to drop it off and he scores oh what a
feed from CER holding trying to feed it down low
Carlson back out top to cter again a wrist shot
score think that hit a Canadian on the way to the
net scor's mind the puck comes to him we're going
to see it unfold here Aiden Hill trying to make
a play trying to understand oops H somebody fell
on him in front Stevenson into the Zone backand
pass don't carry a score hary P again back up
top Coffield across hurry penard that beat score
guess who the captain five games deciding shootout
goals for him as we go to the top of the fourth
backand score off the back bar and right back out